♪♪
Narrator: THE FIRST COMPUTERS
USED TO BE THE SIZE
OF AN ENTIRE ROOM.
THEN THEY WERE BUILT
TO FIT ON YOUR DESK.
THE NEWEST DESIGN IS A PORTABLE
DEVICE THAT SITS ON YOUR LAP,
AND TODAY'S LAPTOPS ARE MADE
EVEN SMALLER
AND MORE POWERFUL THAN EVER.
WITH ITS LIGHTNING-FAST
PROCESSOR
AND IMPRESSIVE GRAPHICS,
THIS LAPTOP IS DESIGNED
FOR HIGH-PERFORMANCE GAMING.
THE COMPUTER'S BRAIN,
CALLED THE MOTHERBOARD,
BEGINS AS
A PRINTED CIRCUIT BOARD.
ITS PATTERN OF LINES
AND PADS AND COPPER
IS THE WIRING
FOR THE ELECTRONIC COMPONENTS
THAT WILL BE SOLDERED
TO THE BOARD.
THIS MACHINE PLACES A STENCIL
OF THE COMPONENT LAYOUT
ONTO THE BOARD
AND APPLIES SOLDER PASTE
THROUGH THE OPENINGS.
A QUALITY-INSPECTION CAMERA
PHOTOGRAPHS THE SOLDER PASTE
AND SENDS THE IMAGES
TO A COMPUTER.
THE COMPUTER ANALYZES THEM,
LOOKING FOR ANY MISSING PASTE,
MISALIGNMENT, OR OTHER MISTAKES.
IF THE BOARD PASSES INSPECTION,
IT PASSES THROUGH
15 ROBOTIC MACHINES,
EACH OF WHICH PLACES UP
TO 150 COMPONENTS
ON THE CORRECT LOCATIONS
ON THE BOARD IN JUST 30 SECONDS.
THEN THE BOARD RUNS
THROUGH AN OVEN
THAT MELTS THE SOLDER PASTE,
CONNECTING THE COMPONENTS
TO THE BOARD.
ANOTHER CAMERA INSPECTION
ENSURES
THAT THE INTERNAL PROCESSOR
IS CORRECTLY SOLDERED,
AND THAT NO COMPONENT IS MISSING
OR SHIFTED OUT OF POSITION.
AFTER FUNCTION TESTING
AND A VISUAL INSPECTION,
THE MOTHERBOARD
MOVES TO THE ASSEMBLY LINE
AND IS SET ASIDE
FOR THE TIME BEING.
NEXT, TECHNICIANS MANUALLY
ASSEMBLE THE TOP HALF
OF THE LAPTOP
CALLED THE PANEL KIT.
THEY PLACE PROTECTION FILM
ON THE 15-INCH L.C.D. SCREEN.
THEN THEY PLUG IN THE CABLE
THAT WILL CONNECT THE L.C.D.
TO THE MOTHERBOARD.
THEY INSERT THE L.C.D. SCREEN
INTO A FRAME WITH A WEB CAMERA
AND MICROPHONE ALREADY EMBEDDED.
THEN THEY ATTACH THIS ANTENNA
BOTTOM COVER TO THE SCREEN COVER
AND POSITION
THE MOTHERBOARD CABLE INSIDE IT.
NEXT, THEY INSTALL THE MODULE
FOR THE WEBCAM AND MICROPHONE.
THEY ATTACH TWO HINGES,
WHICH CONNECT THIS PANEL KIT
TO THE REST OF THE LAPTOP.
THEN THEY INSTALL
THE WI-FI ANTENNA
IN THE ANTENNA BOTTOM COVER.
♪♪
ALL COMPONENTS ARE CONCEALED
IN THE ANTENNA BOTTOM COVER
BEHIND THIS ANTENNA TOP COVER.
THEY COMPLETE THE PANEL KIT
BY PRESSING IN A THIN METAL
FRAME AROUND THE SCREEN.
♪♪
NEXT, THEY ASSEMBLE THE BOTTOM
HALF OF THE LAPTOP.
FIRST, TECHNICIANS ATTACH
THE TOP COVER
TO THE PANEL-KIT HINGES
AND THE TOUCHPAD.
♪♪
THEN THEY INSTALL THE RIGHT AND
LEFT SPEAKERS IN THE TOP COVER.
NOW THE MOTHERBOARD
COMES BACK INTO PLAY.
AFTER INSPECTION,
A COMPUTER-GUIDED ROUTER
CUTS OUT OPENINGS TO ACCOMMODATE
THE COMPUTER'S FANS,
WHICH PREVENT THE ELECTRONICS
FROM OVERHEATING.
A GAMING LAPTOP GENERATES A LOT
MORE HEAT THAN A REGULAR LAPTOP
AND THEREFORE REQUIRES TWO
POWERFUL FANS RATHER THAN ONE.
AFTER CHECKING
THAT THE FAN SCREWS
ARE SUFFICIENTLY TIGHTENED,
THEY PLACE THE MOTHERBOARD
INTO THE TOP COVER.
CONTAMINANTS SUCH AS DUST OR OIL
CAN IMPEDE PROPER CONTACT,
SO AS A PRECAUTION,
THEY CLEAN THE CONNECTORS
FOR THE MEMORY MODULES
WITH SOLVENT,
THEN DRY THEM
WITH COMPRESSED AIR.
THEN THEY INSTALL
THE MEMORY MODULE,
THE WI-FI AND BLUETOOTH MODULE,
AND THE SOLID-STATE DISC,
WHICH STORES DATA.
THEY CONNECT A HIGH-CAPACITY
BATTERY TO THE MOTHERBOARD.
BATTERIES FOR GAMING LAPTOPS
ARE TYPICALLY LARGER
BECAUSE THE FASTER PROCESSOR AND
DUAL FANS CONSUME MORE POWER.
THE LAST COMPONENT IS
THE KEYBOARD,
WHICH FITS INTO
A RECTANGULAR OPENING
IN THE TOP COVER
OF THE BOTTOM HALF.
A LASER-ETCHING MACHINE
MARKS THE REQUIRED
INFORMATION UNDERNEATH.
AN AUTOMATED MACHINE TESTS
NUMEROUS FUNCTIONS,
AND A QUALITY-CONTROL TEAM
TESTS SEVERAL OTHERS,
INCLUDING THE VIRTUAL-REALITY
FEATURE...
...THE L.C.D. AND KEYBOARD
COLOR DISPLAYS...
AND THE KEYS.
NOT ONLY MUST THE KEYS
FUNCTION PROPERLY,
THEY NEED TO BE DURABLE,
SO ENTHUSIASTIC GAMERS
WON'T BREAK THEM WHILE PLAYING.
♪♪